Dear city leaders. Politicians. Decisionmakers.
In the name of all cyclists, I
have an important message for you.
THIS IS NOT BICYCLE INFRASTRUCTURE.
This is a constant near death
experience for adrenaline junkies.
This is proper bicycle infrastructure. Physically
separated from high speed motor traffic.
Or this, even. Not as good, but at least
cars don’t have to constantly dodge you.
What, you don’t like fearing for your life when
cars pass you by at high speeds at arm's length?
Not, not really. I’m weird like that.
As a rule of thumb, if you can’t imagine groups
like pensioners or schoolchildren cycling on a
given bike path, it’s a bad bike path. Bike
infrastructure shouldn’t be tailored solely
around fit young adult men in professional biking
gear, who have nothing to fear or nothing to lose.
So here’s what you should be doing. Take a
road. Take one lane, separate it from the rest,
and turn it into a dedicated bike lane.
Congratulations! You now have proper bike
infrastructure that people can safely use on
an everyday basis, without the fear of death.
This has been a message from
cyclists to city decision makers.
Thank you for your kind attention.